[Music]
[Applause]
let me get to our Buddy Darren Revell he
is a business reporter for the Action
Network and we figured we'd talk to him
about what that ball was worth last
night the 60th home run ball that the
fan gave back to Aaron judge street
value what would that be on the open
market today
at least a hundred thousand Dan so let's
go over this trade again all right the
guy got a ball signed by Aaron judge a
ball signed by Aaron judge for each of
his three friends and a bat signed by
Aaron judge so he essentially gave
fifteen hundred dollars in value for a
hundred thousand easy now there is an
argument to be made he got to meet him
in the clubhouse and take a picture the
picture has more value in the social
media era than ever before right picture
with Aaron judge look at this picture
with Aaron judge after he hit 60. but
obviously not a fair trade and I would
suggest it also looks bad on the Yankees
so if the Yankees want home run ball 61
and 62 they better start uh figuring out
a better deal because they're not going
to get it
would it be prudent to sell the ball
right away or do you wait let's say you
got 62. do you sell it the next day or
do you wait a little while no the way
the auctions work you're just gonna have
to you're probably just gonna have to
wait a month you know you need it to be
marketed but but it's it's interesting I
mean listen we're at a time right now
where game use stuff is going crazy that
Michael Jordan jersey from game one of
the 98 finals so for 10 million dollars
maradona's hand of God jersey sold for
nine million dollars it's at a perfect
time right now as far as game used
memorabilia goes
um but you know we'll have to see right
so 61 probably a half a million dollar
ball 62 the AL record the Yankee record
maybe a million dollar ball and then
what 74 if he could ever get there
um that's that's a big one but Todd
McFarland is still sitting on all his
McGuire and Sosa balls and bought the
bonds he bought Bond 73 too
but what are those worth now what were
they worth then and what are they worth
now well he spent he's what he spent he
spent 3.3 million to get McGuire 60
[Music]
162
and 7 69 and 70 Sosa
6162 and uh and then he paid 500 000 for
bonds 73 so let's say 3.8 million he
spent I bet he could get
one five for those now
a depreciating asset
yeah
yeah I wondered about memorabilia
because on one hand as you talked about
you got some of these items that are
going for crazy amounts of money and
then you have other items that were did
go for crazy amounts of money that
aren't worth it
um what is the what's the Aaron judge
bat worth see that's what I would want
I'll give you the ball back I want the
bat that you hit the home run with well
the bat the bat is the item you go after
right because the Jersey he probably had
six jerseys on last night so if you ask
for the Jersey it's like well what
inning Jersey you're going to give me
did everybody learn from Pete Rose is
that why you change your jerseys out
when Pete yeah
Pete Rose did it um and then I think
that just became a thing
um Brady even did it right with some
with some Super Bowls it's a little
harder as an NFL player but yeah the
Jersey Swap and each inning Cal Ripken
did it uh for him breaking uh he every
inning he put on a new jersey for him
breaking Garrick so uh yeah that's the
thing so I would the bad is definitely
the thing you go after whether a judge
will give you I mean I don't think he'd
give you the bat the bat if it's not
cracked is kind of sacred even though he
has a whole brand of you know bats down
the line I think the Yankees should
should do something with their sponsors
like basically say hey sponsors why
don't we try to get a fair deal for one
of these fans
um you know because this morning it's
all about like oh this guy got taken he
got scammed he's like okay well he's a
horrible negotiator but the Yankees
really didn't do it do themselves any
favors either
uh got anything else that's uh auctioned
or uh this day in history we got we got
three you know I so I have a ticket
collection and I and I uh I organize it
by date so we have three anniversaries
today we have the Rocky Marciano uh his
last fight at Yankee Stadium 49-0 says
September 20th it was postponed today so
that's and then he of course retired uh
what a half a year later at 32. yeah
beat aren't you more yeah and then we
have
now let's put it this way uh we have uh
Harry Carey and Ryan sandberg's last
game at Wrigley 25 years ago today
um so we got that one and then this is
my most impressive one it is a press
pass to the first Monday Night Football
game today is September 21st
1970. it is how would costell from
Cleveland stadium with my fellow
broadcasters Don Meredith and Keith
Jackson
I have all these press passes in here
get them slabbed I'll help uh we'll
let's all let's get them slabbed for you
I but they're all over the doors like
I've got from Jordan's uh you gotta get
you got listen you got to get those I'll
I'll help you but you gotta you gotta
put those things get them in these nice
slabs and uh and uh other than hanging
some of them are worth a lot of money
could you give me the street value if
you came here to the man cave and you
just walked around and saw what I had in
here that would be a great that would be
a great segment that would be a great
and we'll and we'll we'll make it like
each time I say something we go ding
ding ding and then at the end we just
added them all up I was thinking of
getting American Pickers to come in here
and do a show great idea but I'm a
better estimator than they are
uh the Brady Bowl what we thought was
the last touchdown pass did that just
sell that just sold for like a hundred
and twenty nine thousand dollars which
by the way I was shocked at so
originally the guy bought it for 518
000. he 24 hours later Brady's like oh
I'm unretiring the guy's like I'm not
paying for that they let it go and then
they resell it I'm like it's gonna sell
for like 25 000. it's all for 129 000
it's still got 25 of the value which
like okay it's now it's just like a
random like touchdown and a loss
um that is just an example of how crazy
game use memorabilia is going you can't
get anything for for for any value these
days what do you think Jordan's jersey
for game six when he hit the jumper
against Utah
I think that's probably right now in
current market probably a 20 million
dollar piece
you know somebody has Michael's Shoes
from that game well
I've been I was privy to see some things
happen after Michael won championships
he always came into SportsCenter when I
was on site and he never had it out of
here he never had his shoes on
right they were always off his shoes by
the time you were doing the interview
that is a fascinating nugget that's
that's pretty much somebody
I witnessed Michael's signing
his shoes I don't know if he said too
I'm I'm just saying I I think that
there's some exploratory work well I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna have to do
that work now the flu game shoes were
sold like five years ago for a hundred
and four thousand that guy who's the he
was the Utah Jazz ball boy yeah man he
is that's a bargain he oh complete
bargain that's at least a couple million
dollars yes now the problem with the
Jordan shoes is
they really do start to disintegrate the
foam is not the greatest so especially
like Jordan one through five or six not
good
so you have to take that into account
because it's like you know you buy it
then you go see it you know two years
later in your safety deposit box and
you're like where's the shoe it's gone
yeah but you can hermetically seal those
things
foreign man I don't know if there's a a
shoe aging agent that you could put on
it I'm not sure someone better invent it
though I actually see so I I I was
um a a bidder on the Steve Prefontaine
Oregon waffle shoes at Sotheby's
um my only problem was Prefontaine did
not
use the shoes in a race right he used
spikes he was running fast races around
a track and so the shoes were amazing
Oregon waffle but he never wore them or
he never wore them while he was running
a race so I went to Nike and I'm like do
you have anything in the archives that
shows that Steve Prefontaine wearing
these shoes like in a practice anything
nothing and if I didn't have that
picture I was like oh I can't bid on him
then so you really got to do a lot of
work as things get higher and higher on
some of these deals what do you think my
Ryan Leaf Colts jersey is worth
that it was given to oh it was given it
it was made yes just in case he was
picked instead of Peyton yeah actually I
think that's an incredible Conversation
Piece as as uh as well people probably
won't remember this but I will and you
will Ryan Leaf was the was the number
one I mean he I remember Bob glauber did
a piece on from from all these uh
general managers and like Leaf was the
unanimous decision here at the time so
people would be like well who would have
that and it's like well you know polian
made the right decision but like Leaf
was definitely won over Peyton at the
time that was the thinking so I love
that Jersey that is awesome good to talk
to you as always Darren you got it I
touched Aaron Revell Action Network
business reporter